It's great to welcome to the program today
Maximillian Alvarez, who's a writer based
in Baltimore,
dual phd candidate in history and comparative
literature at the University of Michigan and
also the whole host of working people, a podcast
by four and about the working class today.
It's so great to have you on today.
I appreciate your time.
Thanks David.
Thanks for having me.
So let's just jump right in and talk a little
bit about, I mean, I guess even how to introduce
the subject is already sort of part of the
issue.
Do we want to talk about fascism?
Do we want to talk about and Tifo do we want
to talk about protest movements?
I mean, I don't really know what the right
way to frame the conversation is.
So maybe I'll let you do it.
I mean, what do you think is the fundamental,
um, uh, sort of crux of what we should be
talking about right now regarding the movement
against fascism that is often seen through
protests in the media?
[inaudible]
yeah, I mean, I think, I think that's a great
question.
I think that's the question that we should
all be asking, right?
Because I think that, you know, one of the
biggest, um, constraints to, you know, anti-fascist
politics is, is I'm kind of waiting through
all the kind of negative, uh, portrayals and
biases that, you know, we get in the media
of anti fascism or that we kind of absorb
from the environment about what anti fascism
is.
And, you know, part of the work that I do
and so many others do is try to, you know,
really get into kind of the meat and bones
of, of what anti-fascist politics is and tried
to kind of get people to understand that,
you know, any fascism shouldn't be a bad thing.
Right?
You know, it's a, you know, living a life
that is expressly non fascist, right?
That is, that is devoted to preventing, you
know, fascism or fascist like politics from
ever emerging again.
You know, that that should be a thing that
we should all want.
And so in that regard, I think, um, you know,
what's really important is to kind of understand
what the stakes are of preventing fascism
or fascist like politics from growing in this
country or beyond this country and the ways
that, you know, every day working people are
more closely aligned with the politics of
anti fascism, then I think they realize, but
again, we tend to kind of associate any fascism
as such, you know, with a couple of like repeated
media portrayals of certain tactics of certain
anti-fascist groups.
Um, that really missed the larger picture
of how the point of anti fascism, right, is
to inoculate our society from kinds of the,
the conditions that lead people to find fascism
attractive.
Right.
This is, this is a conversation that, you
know, I've been having and that others have
been having since before Donald Trump was
elected.
Right.
Because I think, I think, you know, Jeff [inaudible],
who's a professor at the University of Michigan
and a specialist in the politics of Nazi Germany,
you know, put it really well, you know, when
he, when he said that, you know, we get into
a lot of discussions about whether or not
Donald Trump is fascist, whether or not this
or that policy is fascist, this or that group
of people as Fascist.
And that gets us bogged down kind of in, um,
you know, I think a kind of roundabout discussion
about whether or not our historical conditions
right now in the American president kind of
map on, you know, beat by beat to the conditions
of, you know, Germany in the 1920 and 1930s
or Italy, you know, with the rise of Mussolini
and [inaudible].
You know, I think that's, that's, it's kind
of like a amazed without an exit, right?
Because history is never gonna kind of repeat
itself point by point.
And I think that Jeff Juliis, I'm a really
instructive here when he says that, you know,
history is never gonna repeat itself precisely.
And so the more important question is not
to ask whether or not you know this or that
person is, you know, fascist by some sort
of kind of textbook definition that leads
us to believe that there is only like one
kind of historical, um, kind of potion for
creating fascism.
Right?
The question is like, what sorts of historical
conditions lead more and more people, a critical
mass of people to find fascism or fascist,
like politics more attractive to, to
focus in on what you said about the portrayals
in media.
I mean, as so I consider myself most aligned
with the political movement called social
democracy.
And when I look at social democracy, I see
an anti fascist worldview and anti-fascist
ideology.
When you look at fascism as, you know, this
right wing, um, often very nationalist authoritarianism
that sometimes has dictatorial power, but
not always like, as you're talking about,
it's not always exactly the same.
I can think of no, uh, progressive ideology
of any kind that wouldn't be strongly against
that.
And so what I wanted to kind of pose to you
is when you talk about the media portrayals
of people in whatever city who are, you know,
doing some violent act or whatever the case
may be, have they perverted the antifascist
movement or are they in a sense, uh, I mean,
I see a contradiction in the tactics as you
talk about of some in that they f they are
very authoritarian tactics claiming to fight
against a slightly different form of authoritarianism.
So what is the kind of right way to interpret
those tactics and the media portrayals thereof?
So can I ask a quick clarifying question?
Um, what you mean in that context by authoritarian
tactic?
Well, I, uh, in, in my view, um, if I were
to, um, decide that in order to protest some
version of authoritarianism, I am going to,
um, foist acts of violence among, uh, upon
people who are just existing in society and
trying to go about their life for example,
or working a job or whatever the case may
be.
To me, that seems like an authoritarian tactic,
which I am engaging in, in order to fight.
Suppose that authoritarianism, and I don't
mean suppose it in the sense that I don't
believe it's there.
I do, but what I identify as authoritarianism,
I am saying, I am going to impose what I see
as a solution to authoritarianism with something
that is in a sense also authoritarian.
Okay. [inaudible] yeah.
I mean, I, I think I, um, so I, I get where
you're coming from and you know, I know that
this is a conversation that, um, we kind of
get bogged down in, right?
Is, you know, a lot of, a lot of folks when
they're talking about antifascist politics,
you know, they, they, um, kind of require
that in order to even have the conversation,
we need to kind of condemn certain tactics
as violent and counterproductive.
And I, and I 100% get where you're coming
from.
Um, in terms of, of the optics of these sorts
of tactics and you know, how much they sync
up with a broader, you know, movement, a more
popularized movement of, um, you know, every
day anti fascism.
And you know, I think, um, I think the, the,
when, when we're asked to kind of condemned
certain violent tactics, like black block
tactics, I mean black block itself is not
even like a, an expressly unnecessarily violent
tactic.
A lot of it is based on, um, kind of community
defense.
I mean, if you look at like the j 20 trials,
you can see exactly why people wear masks
because the government tried to kind of, um,
in, in an almost unprecedented way charge
of over 300 people with, I'm kind of conspiracy
to riot just cause they were wearing the same
thing.
And that's because they couldn't pick out
any single one person because of the masks.
And that's part of the kind of protective
tactic.
But to the point that you're asking about,
you know, if, um, you know, and then someone
punches Richard Spencer or if like a bank
of America window gets broken and that this
as you as you said, is I'm the optics of this
are kind of protestors, um, foisting I think
he said like a certain, you know, what looks
like an authoritarian tactic onto, you know,
a presumably neutral kind of world or neutral
people.
You know, I think that that's why it's so
important, um, to kind of understand what
the stakes of anti fascism are.
Because I think what any fascism argues is
that, you know, this sort of framing of the
question kind of presumes a certain state
of normal nonviolence that we live in every
day or that we aren't endorsing certain forms
of violence already and that these, um, tactics
are not in any way sprechen of, um, frustration
and desperation against the preexisting forms
of violence that exist in our society.
Maybe we, we may just disagree as to what
tactics are acceptable, which would be fine.
I mean that's a reasonable disagreement to
have, but I guess in, in order to figure that
out, the um, I mean I don't disagree that
for example, the financial system status quo
that we have in the United States, um, confers
or, uh, includes a type of violence against,
you know, the average person who has either
a student loan or ends up needing payday loans
or you know, overdrafts endlessly because
they already don't have money.
So the bank then is charging, I get that there
is a form of violence in that, but I guess
in order to inform our audience who may not
be familiar with you, is that, would that
type of violence be, uh, countered with something
like punching someone in the face?
Do you see them as equivalent in some way?
Or You did mention some unproductive tactics,
maybe I'm wondering which ones you meant by
that.
We may just have a different lists so to speak.
Yeah, no, I mean, I mean I again, I think,
and I appreciate, you know, the, the framing
of the question cause I think this is a productive
way to discuss things.
I mean, you know, I would say first and foremost,
I, I do not see myself in any position to,
um, kind of judge the tactics of people that
I'm not organizing with.
Right.
I've been in situations where people have
done things that I think are endangering the,
the bulk of us.
And we will hash that out.
Um, internally, like if people, you know,
are provoking police from the outside, while
a group of us are kind of face to face with
the police, it is not tactically sound right
to kind of go police into arresting us when,
you know, we could possibly avoid that.
But at the same time, like I said, like, um,
you know, I, I do not feel like I have any
place, um, to judge kind of the, the expressions
of frustration and desperation that people
feel when, as you said, you know, we, we,
we live in such a kind of perpetual state
of everyday violence, um, that the politics
of fascism kind of exacerbates and accentuates,
you know, like as we create further into it.
And you know, that's, that's I think what
my biggest problem is with, um, kind of the,
the framing of the violence question, right?
Because while I think many average people
you know, are, are again expressly committed
to not wanting fascism in this country, you
know, I think that their knee jerk kind of
a revulsion to kind of seeing someone get
punched or a window getting broken.
I think it comes from a good place.
But what I would ask people to consider is
that, you know, how that question of condemning
violence from protestors in the same way that
we are asked to condemn the violence of, you
know, um, black protesters after, you know,
Darren Wilson kills, you know, a, a young
black kid, you know, like near St Louis or
here in Baltimore where I am, you know, oh,
we're asking ourselves not to see context,
right?
We're asking ourselves not to, we're asking
ourselves to pretend that it's not incredibly
weird and bad that we only ever seem to apply
the term violence to the powerless know.
So I guess it depends on who we're talking
about though.
I think that there are plenty of people who
have a more nuanced view, which is there are
actually multiple types of violence and one,
one may recognize that and not believe that,
for example, punching someone is morally equivalent
to a form of violence, for example, from a
financial institution.
But because you're right that it is really,
you know, you were, I'm not, you said you
don't want to judge necessarily and you talk
about the revulsion.
Let's maybe, I mean I am a very pragmatic
thinker, maybe to a fault when I think of
the pragmatic effect of some of these tactics,
given that I share the goal of being against
fascism, that's where a lot of my concern
comes from.
Where I wonder what is the end game and how
might some of those tactics ultimately achieved
the change that I want.
I don't see it and that's why I, without having
to ask, I have not ever been asked to denounce
this, that, or the other thing other than
once Richard Spencer asked me if I Denounce
Pol Pot and I said, yes I do.
That's an easy one, but that's a story for
another day.
I've said, I don't endorse these tactics because
I fundamentally, aside from my moral assessment,
don't think that they will achieve the change
that I want.
And maybe the pragmatics are more easy to
discuss than the morality [inaudible]
I think.
Yeah.
I so that I, I definitely understand, um,
more right, because, yeah, I think, I think,
um, to your point, but if we get bogged down
in a, like a moral discussion about violence
and pacifism, right?
Like, like we were saying, you end up getting,
you know, backing yourself into kind of a
logical corner where you are blinding yourself
to all the existing forms of violence that,
um, kind of produce this sort of, um, you
know, political outrage, political desperation
and, and people feeling the need to defend
their communities, um, and using whatever
tactics they have available to them, especially
when the state itself is not listening to
them.
You know, Martin Luther King famously said
that riots are the voice of the unheard.
Right.
And I think that that, you know, is another
part, another ingredient to the question of,
you know, how close we are to fascist and
fascist like politics is when people lose
faith in, you know, government having any
sort of ability to kind of address these issues.
You know, they, they, they need to turn to
community defense.
And then when I think we'd get into the, you
know, the, the real, um, tissue of the question
that you asked, okay.
Like if this is, this is what we're up against,
then how tactically sound, you know, like
is it to, to, um, you know, go in this or
that direction.
And here is where I think, again, the, the
politics of everyday anti fascism is so crucial,
right?
Because, um, I mean, you know, we live in
a sensationalist, you know, kind of media
environment, you know, it's just kind of the
world that we live in and naturally the, the,
you know, clip of Richard Spencer getting
punched as the thing that just gets way more,
um, play.
Then all the rest of, you know, like any fascist
politics that occurs, you know, and to their
credit, there are groups across the United
States, whether it's like pop mob in Portland,
you know, even like DSA, you know, like rose
city antifa there's so many groups that are
doing any fascism in ways that, um, tactically
I think are more aligned with what you're
asking.
Because again, the goal is to inoculate our
society from fascism taking root.
And the way that you do that right is to build
community, to build solidarity, to protect
one another, to, to find, um, you know, joy
in, in your community, in ways that kind of
prevent lonely, desperate, angry people from
latching themselves on to a reactionary, vicious,
violent, um, you know, jingoistic and, and
ethno nationalist point of view.
I just don't see some of the tactics that,
that I've seen employed, uh, achieving that.
In other words, I think that they generate,
um, more unrest and fear and all the, I mean,
listen here, here's where I think I'm struggling
with the I, I would never, I don't believe
in universal disarmament and I would never
sort of preemptively suggest here's the list
of things that no matter how bad it gets,
no one should or will ever do.
I think that that is a, is a problem as you're
pointing out.
However, when half the country doesn't vote,
I mean, okay, a lot of people say voting doesn't
really matter because the system is set up
to make it so that it doesn't really matter.
We've not tried it.
Half the doesn't vote on every recent election
at certainly the national level, if not state
level.
And even at more local levels.
If we had full voter engagement, we would
have a drastically different situation.
Right now there's a whole list of other tactics
I've talked about, including mass rallies
that urban centers, uh, strategic loan defaults,
which would cripple the finance.
You know, there's this whole long list of
stuff that's never been done that doesn't
go to physical violence.
So I'm not ready to say it's, we're at the
point where those are the tactics.
That would be the next ones on my list.
Then of course people can disagree with that.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I mean, you know, I wrote this article
for the Baffler last year called anti fascism
in the left sphere of power where, you know,
we were, we were talking about different tactics.
Um, but I think it overlaps somewhat with
the discussion that we're having here, right?
Because again, I, I get where you're coming
from and I think that from a tactical discussion,
we didn't have a more productive back and
forth then, you know, if we get bogged down
in a moral discussion about absolute passivism
and you know, this was a criticism that we
faced, you know, in the Stop Spencer coalition
when we were mobilizing against Richard Spencer's
impending pending appearance at Michigan State
and the University of Michigan.
You know, we got a lot of pushback in including
from people on the left who said, you know,
like this is not tactically sound.
It is going to turn people against you.
Just ignore, you know, Richard Spencer and
the KKK members and all the white nationalists
who were surrounding our community.
We knew we're going to be there and we who
we knew were going to use this opportunity
to occupy our, to our community and instill
fear in the people that you are most vulnerable
in our communities.
And you know, I think that, um, just like
we were talking about kind of the, the presumption
of violence only existing when, um, you know,
people, um, kind of lash out after sustaining
just years and years and years of oppressive
violence from the state, from the economy,
let alone from, you know, structures of racism,
misogyny, um, you know, homophobia so on and
so forth.
Right.
Just in that sort of way, you know, the, the
presumption that, um, that we are not already
kind of backsliding on, you know, like a kind
of political hill, you know, I think his is
tactically unsound.
I think that, you know, for those who were
criticizing us for saying that this was only
going to give like the right more ammunition
to kind of police descent on campus communities,
my response was like, do you think they're
not doing that already?
Like they've been doing this ready.
I guess I might approach it from a slightly
more macro perspective, which is when I think
about the big advancements of the last hundred
and 20 years and I'm complete, I may just
have the history wrong on this and that's
PR.
We would sort that out.
It seems as though they have been linked to
a particular type of activism that did not
rely on these tactics.
So when I think about like the new deal of
the post World War II era, when I think about
Martin Luther King who you mentioned, when
I think about some of the significant, I mean
it's not enough, but the, in the context significant
regulatory advancements of the late eighties
and early nineties.
When I think about that stuff, it seems that
although we may all agree it's not enough,
that those are pretty significant advancements
that we can point to that came primarily on
the back of not what we would call non-fee.
I'm distinguishing nonphysically violent activism.
Am I just wrong about the history?
[inaudible]
no, I think you're, I mean, I think you're
right, but I think again, um, like I was saying
with my problem with the question about like
condemning violence is that it's asking us
to ignore context.
I think that we, we all, I mean this is just
the way that, that we look at history, right?
It's impossible to kind of know everything
that was going on at the time.
And so, you know, through history books and
narratives, right?
We get a more, uh, distilled version of what
happened.
And I think that putting these, you know,
great and, and important nonviolent movements
in context is really important.
Right?
Because, you know, for, for Martin Luther
King and, and many factions of the civil rights
movement, nonviolence was a very important
tactic to maintain.
But it was also taking place within the context
of increasing militancy from other, you know,
like a factions of a civil rights and, and
kind of, you know, uh, black, um, liberatory
movement, right.
That that was also informing the decisions
that people in power, right.
You know, you know, just the, the march on
Washington would not have scared, you know,
the white establishment as much if they were
not also, you know, like thinking about, you
know, like armed, um, you know, black citizens
kind of like protecting their communities.
Right?
Or if they hadn't seen, you know, what, what,
you know, responses, communities are, are
kind of left with when, you know, they feel
like there's nowhere to turn and they're facing
violence from the state every day.
And so I think that that, you know, history
is messy and there are always kind of more
complicated contexts than we give it credit
for.
It seems like we definitely are on the same
page in terms of a lot of the context.
It does seem like the fundamental area of
disagreement is not maybe both to some degree
the practicality and also the morality of
some particular tactics, but I a really appreciate
that we were able to discuss it.
Um, in this way we've been speaking with Maximilian
Alvarez who's a writer based in Baltimore
Dual Phd candidate, uh, at the University
of Michigan and also host of working people,
a podcast by four and about the working class
today.
Really appreciate your time and hope to be
able to speak again in the future.
Thanks David.
Really appreciate it.